comme l'an passé se déroule là qu'était
dans le val de marne l'opération anti
rouille plus de 5000 heures d'activités
diverses sont proposées aux jeunes qui
ne partent pas en vacances cela va de
l'informatique à la construction d'un
catamaran leur poste le reportage de
pascal sorgues la rouille
c'est dans le charbon des jeunes de la
rue l'ennui alors pour parer à cet ennui
fondamentales structurelles
la ville de créteil réitère l'opération
anti rouille une entreprise d'envergure
puisqu'elle concerne pour la seule
période du 1er au 15 juillet plus de
3200 adolescents antirouille c'est aussi
le moyen de parer à la petite
délinquance qui s'installe pendant l'été
les lianes y est nous avons observé une
baisse très nette de la délinquance mais
je crois qu'il ne s'agit pas uniquement
d'un quand il s'agit aussi de tout ce
qui n'est pas comptabilisée comme
délinquance c'est à dire un peu ce mal
vivre qui s'exprime
durant les périodes comme les vacances
c'est à dire les déprédations sur des
équipements publics
la détérioration du mobilier urbain je
prépare son tuba le masque on n'oublie
pas des individus
l'objectif d'antirouille organiser des
vacances à la ville pour les jeunes de
13 à 18 ans toutes les activités sont
gratuits des ateliers fonctionnent toute
la journée jusqu'à 20 heures le soir
allez bien oui c'est très bien si bien
vivre n'est souvent conduit et puis
c'est bien ce qu'a nié on a beaucoup de
copains copines c'est sympa non de
réguler ou beaucoup initiative originale
lordinot bus de plein air un bus
itinérant équipé de matériel
informatique
on peut s'initier à la
micro-informatique faire des programmes
ou plus simplement jouer les plus mordus
ils passent toute leur journée
parallèlement des livres et des machines
à écrire sont mises à la disposition de
tous
la musique n'est pas laissé pour compte
puisque un studio d'enregistrement est
mise à la disposition des groupes qui
veulent s'enregistrer un atelier qui
marche très très fort puisque le
planning du mois de juillet est déjà
saturé
saku tiède enregistre un disque ici
sinon à enregistrer un disque que sinon
bon il paraît que c'est très cher
surtout pour avoir une qualité de son
mais la chance qu'on a eues ici c'est de
pouvoir enregistrer gratuitement ou
l'opération anti rouille une
organisation non directive des loisirs
qui peut aussi motiver les jeunes